so if i bring him up to here he just has
potential energy and he's not moving so
there's no kinetic energy and as i let
him go he swings backwards and forwards
between the same places more or less
so big e is the symbol that gets used
for energy uh and it sort of crops up
all over the place in physics uh
probably in the most famous equation of
them all e equals m c squared the e in
that is the energy of something it's
just something which is always conserved
so it's either nuclear energy energy
associated with mass equals m c squared
it's energy associated with thermal
motion or it can be an electromagnetic
field it can have many different forces
the forms but if you add all these
things together at each stage and keep
the bookkeeping it is that quantity
which is always conserved but i'm not
going to tell you what it is because
it's one of those deep mysteries
so if one of your kids said dad what is
energy how would you answer that that's
a tough question what is energy have you
got a dictionary george
i've got one upstairs we'll look it up
another day okay
you see it's how much oomph something's
got but that's not really a very
scientific definition is it really
energy comes in many different forms and
the normal ones we talk about are energy
due to motion which is called kinetic
energy and energy due to position which
is called potential energy although
there are all these different kinds of
energy you can there's kind of an
exchange rate between them so you can
actually interchange you know you can
change your potential energy into
kinetic energy by dropping something for
example so they are all really the same
thing
but it's just stored in different forms
so you can have the chemical energy
stored in a battery for example which
you can then turn into kinetic energy
when you plug that battery into a motor
and so i touch here this is just a
battery there's a magnet down here and
as i touch it it spins round like mad
and as i leave it you'll see
it's not a perpetual motion machine
unless i leave the electrical contact it
slows down it slows down and comes to a
stop so if you're a child on a swing and
you move backwards that's energy super
position but if you let it go and it
moves that's energy due to motion so i'd
like you to imagine how this was given
to me my son for christmas it's very
strange when you're a physicist what you
get given for presents at christmas but
this is my albert einstein doll complete
with a bit of chalk what did you think
when you were given that oh i had to say
how wonderful it is and he's going to be
watching this it was wonderful peter
anyway imagine einstein is a pole
vaulter and he's charging along with
this meter rule pretending to be pole
vaulting
and he comes all the way along to the
little place where he puts it in the
hole and this gets bent and bent and
bent
and now you all the energy his kinetic
energy of motion has been turned into
bending energy of this rod and then he
comes up as this
unfurls and he now just has potential
energy due to his position but being
einstein he was the wrong way around he
should go over feet first and there will
be a rod and he fall down
so that's
one example where you're converting
kinetic energy of him sprinting as fast
as he can to get as much kinetic energy
into potential energy of this bending of
the pole
into potential energy due to his
position
and if he's very clever he can distort
himself into such a shape that he gets
his feet over first and then his legs
and his arms go up in the air
and he can manage to get over
even though his center of gravity is
below the bar another example for paul
mr einstein i'm going to put him on a
swing
because when i was a child
i never knew how to do the swing
properly and my mother always had to
push me
and so i'm going to fix him up so his
fingers and toes are all wrapped around
this properly and we'll let him swing
so if i bring him up to here he just has
potential energy and he's not moving so
there's no kinetic energy and as i let
him go he swings backwards and forwards
between the same places more or less
but if you notice carefully it's slowing
down
it's slowing down it's not coming back
as far as it did before
the result of
the movement of einstein through the air
and there's some friction and
dissipation of energy here it's all
potential energy and there's nothing
else
here it's partly kinetic because he's
moving and he's reduced his
his potential energy the sum of the two
is constant
when he gets down to the bottom it's all
kinetic energy and there's no potential
energy and the sum is constant apart
from this little loss of energy due to
friction and then it goes up and there
might be some rocking motion that he
does but if you take account of all
sources of energy all sources of energy
then the total is fixed this is the law
of conservation of energy it means that
if you do the accounting properly and
you add up all the terms mathematically
all the terms and then put it as a total
as the time varies this remains constant
and it seems to be one of the most
fundamental laws of nature energy is
conserved there's an older unit of
energy called an erg which is actually
ten to the minus seven of a joule that's
a ten millionth of a joule and for some
reason astronomers insist on holding
onto it as a unit which the rest of the
world threw away decades ago but for
some reason many astronomers insist on
continuing to measure their units in
this and an erg is a pathetically tiny
it's like the kinetic energy of a nat or
something it's a pathetically small unit
so it's completely ridiculous for
astronomy but for some reason just sort
of lost in the midst of time now it's a
unit that astronomers insist on keeping
on using can i now talk about how
kids at school could get this thing to
rock backwards and forwards i could
never do it you can either stand up on
here or you sit down
on your stool and at one part of the
cycle when it's coming back
you tuck your legs under and when you
get to the other part of the cycle where
it's going forward you lean back
and as a result of leaning forward you
lower your center of mass
in other words where your heaviest which
is around here you lower it down and
when you go the other way you're
lowering it down so you're changing
effectively the length of the pendulum
twice in a cycle and if you do this the
right point
if you do it just at the right point you
will increase your energy and everybody
will say how are you getting the energy
higher
and the reason is you're doing work
over the cycle and this is pumping
energy when when olympic gymnasts are
holding onto the bar
and they go round and round in circle
and you can see they got
rosin on their fingers and there's
clearly friction they bend themselves at
one point in the cycle to raise their
center of gravity and that way they pump
energy into the system